welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus stalker on this
episode of the podcast I talk with
Corner Leahy Connor is the CEO of
conjecture which is an organization
dedicated to scalable AI alignment
on this episode we talk about AI safety
and Conor lays out his case for how AI
could become dangerous to humanity
we then discuss two potential solutions
to this problem
slowing down AI development and
regulating it and we talk about why
these Solutions might not be enough
here is Conor Leahy
great Connor Thank you for coming on
I'll be back
what is AI safety how do you how do you
frame this problem because there are a
myriad of of different framings of the
AI safety problem there is a different
terminology what do you find most useful
here
so
over time I've become more and more
pragmatic in trying to like limit the
scope of what we're talking about here
because yeah if you think do things too
expansively you know it just brings a
lot of backage to people like to argue
I think if it just currently what I
usually think about the AI Control
problem is kind of like what I call it
or the alignment problem the sense that
I want
an AI system to do what I want it to do
whatever that means and a even more
paired down version of it is the problem
of controlling a strong system using a
weaker system
where the weaker system in this context
is a human yes yeah
um yeah perhaps you could you could talk
about uh but it's like a good way to to
introduce the topic is to think about
how could ai go wrong all right so what
are some concrete scenarios and I know
they're probably a massive list in your
head right now but how could it go wrong
I mean again
if someone asked me Conor could you
please write down the top 10 ways I
could kill a million people for under
ten thousand dollars I'd be like well I
won't confirm or deny that I could do
that but if I could I wouldn't do that
so there's a similar thing here where
like I can give you know various
scenarios of various concreteness but
like I don't know if you've ever read
this great post I'm less wrong it's not
like uh Tylenol and terrorism or
something it's called uh it's a great
post highly recommend it uh I think
Davis kingly wrote it I'm I'm sorry if
that was not the author I don't remember
it's called like uh
Tylenol terrorism and dangerous
information I think is what the post is
called and it points this is it's one of
my favorite posts about info hazards and
points to this point where there is a
it's been in the 70s or 80s I'm probably
going to get some of the details wrong
but like the gist will be correct
there was a string of poisonings or
unknown person not to this day and don't
know who did it took open Tylenol
bottles in
um shops and put poison into them and so
several people died this was actually
really bad so this is actually a truly
terrible event and so obviously people
freaked the out and like there was
a bunch of like copycats as well
copycats is another interesting topic
that we don't have time to talk about
but that's a whole other memetic danger
topic
um and but the interesting thing here is
is that that had never happened before
like like pills of this kind have
existed for a long time you know it's
like bottles like they didn't have seals
back then so for decades they didn't
have these like seals that they have now
because nowadays when you open a bottle
of pills like there's like seal legit
like pull off they're not supposed to
like if this damage you're like not
supposed to take the pills this is to a
large degree why is it because of these
poisoning attacks that happen
so
there's this massive change in culture
overall and suddenly and after the first
person did it there were dozens of
attacks like these all these copycats or
dozens of attacks like these where
people try to poison medication and
stuff like this in random actor and this
was an extremely effective war of
terrorism like that like I mean I
genuinely like I think this is like
super scary like this is a super scary
attack so we don't no one ever took
credit for those attacks we actually
which is also like very strange like we
still don't know what happened there
um but the interesting thing is
well it happened once and then suddenly
it kept happening and like you know now
that we have seals it's like not a
little much less of a problem but it
really seemed like just like one person
came up with an idea and then it spread
and so this is a great example of an
info Hazard that one of the things that
I've really learned as someone who has a
bit of a security mindset you know I was
a bit of a hacker as a kid I was you
know break things and like you know
think how to get around things and
whatever how could I you know
accomplish your silly things not going
to get around security systems how could
I you know do things that maybe are not
legal and so on I never did of course uh
I was a good kid of course never gotten
take trouble but um
you realized at some point that like a
lot of things that are obvious to maybe
you or me are actually not obvious to a
lot of other people and especially not
bad people most bad people are like
shockingly stupid like truly genuinely
shockingly unintelligent especially like
terrorists they're like and stuff like
that are often just like shockingly
uncreative and intelligent and
giving them ideas might seem like well
you know I've already come up with this
so you know like you know surely someone
else no one else can but often they can
so I'm not going to get my most likely
scenario because my most likely
scenarios involve human actors doing
stupid things and like I can think of a
concrete human actors where I'm like yep
that's they would do that they're
definitely dumb enough to do that but
you know maybe it's not the name but let
me give you a um
let me give you a a slightly the class
the general class of scenarios so there
are scenarios in my mind about like
super intelligence and like take off and
nanotech and like all that crazy stuff
but none of those are my main line I
truly think those are actually
distractions from what I think like the
the minimum viable catastrophe looks
like for me the minimum viable
catastrophe
looks much more like
if you talk to people who work in like
intelligence services or in like
security and stuff like this and you
talk to them about how operations
actually happen and like how
defend against things the Recently I was
talking to a senior person in government
and I'm going to give a concrete example
because this is a fixed problem so this
is no longer they they have solved this
problem so it's no longer unsafe
um
this is like 10 years ago or like five
or ten years ago and they were in like
the office of the government I'm not
going to say which government or which
person but uh and they were talking to
several like you know high-ranking
officials I think like the head of state
was there as well and he looked at
there's this big window this massive you
know open window and he's like what's
stopping some teenager from flying a
drone through that window strapped with
dynamite and killing all of us
nothing and they all just like they all
made excuses are like oh that can happen
but it turns up nope
no one had any protection against that
no one thought about it they could just
anyone could have done that and so the
lesson to learn from this so by the way
they do have anti-drone defenses now
that's why I'm saying that's not a
problem anymore so that that government
now has anti-joint defensive so this is
no longer a threat
um it's still a threat but like you know
they're aware of it it was like five or
ten years ago the
one of my fundamental parts of my model
about AI danger is that the world is
unstable the world currently is
extremely not unstable that's actually
the wrong word it's fragile it's
actually very resistant to smaller
medium shocks it is not at all resistant
against big shocks so I don't think
we've actually seen a big shock since
World War II and even World War II is
like a you know it's a big one but it's
not the biggest that you could imagine
like there have been bigger ones in
history such like the black death or
something I could because they're like
an even bigger shock than World War II
um but since then I I don't think the
world has actually seen a truly big
shock like even like the 2008 financial
crisis is like a medium at most you know
it's like sure it was and like covet
also like medium it's like you know like
on a historical if you look at like
historical context two thousand years
context like yokove was like you know it
wasn't as bad as the Spanish flu and it
wasn't fast Black Death
we've had bigger ones at Humanity got
through just fine so the world I think
is fundamentally fragile in that humans
generally build defenses against like is
again the Black Swan thing they trade
volatility for blow up risks
you know so we'll couch things enough
that you know from day to day mostly
everything's fine you know day-to-day
volatility gets evened out no problem
year to year it mostly gets you know
okay you know some War Down in Africa
happens you know some terrorism over in
the Middle East you know but like you
know for the most part if you live in
the western world or like you know in
Tokyo or something you're fine you don't
notice it we don't buffer well against
you know decade or Century level events
and an example of that is you know after
covet hit and it gave us a warning shot
as far as I'm concerned is what a you
know really bad pandemic could look like
like a black death level pandemic that
looked like
governments are now cutting back on
their pandemic spending and striking
down all bills to increases for future
events hmm
suspicious so the world is very unstable
I think it is at the point where
a lot of I was talking to a senior uh
I'm official at a government who also
has a lot of connections to Security
Services and such and
um we were talking about this and like
you know what holds the world together
like why don't people do all these crazy
attacks we were coming up with uh is it
simply because people are too nice or
too good and most people are either nice
or good or incapable and so we're
relying on the vast majority of people
simply not attempting these uh
I mean it's it's a goodness a goodness
it's just like most people don't
actually want to hurt other people like
not really or at least not randomly you
know like most people want Society to be
stable most people want other people to
be held healthy and happy but you know
so maybe you'll hate like one guy and
you'll be like this guy I want to
kill this guy but like it's very rare
for people to like actually want to kill
many people or like actually or like
harm or maim many people it's actually
rare it it definitely exists but it's
like quite rare and
there's the other and then then another
one is agency intelligence optimization
we're actually well pretty well
protected against people who want to
maim and torture they're not smart they
land in prison you know like low IQ
sociopaths and like there's this meme of
this like you know soci pass or these
Suave intelligent you know manipulative
you know vampires no those are just the
only ones you see most of them just land
in prison and you never see them
again because they're just complete
psychos you know they you know start
torturing animals as kids you know start
beating women by the time they're 14 you
know you know start you know robbing
people by the age they're they're you
know they're eight or whatever like it's
it's like if you want to really see the
Dark World As It exists you should look
up like juvenile sociopath or psycho
psychopathy it's like actually shocking
and so I think I think a lot of people
who don't work in law enforcement aren't
or like Psychiatry aren't aware of it's
just how bad it is like how there are
some people who are just so
incorrigibly evil like truly
incorrigible evil that there is just
nothing you can do but just like throw
them in a cage and just leave them there
because they just cannot rehabit till a
day this is vegan rare like this is not
like this is like a small percentage of
the population but they do exist and
like ignoring that these people exist is
I think actually very dangerous because
it gives you an inactive model about how
reality works and so the point here
would be that AIS would be different
because AIS would be capable and perhaps
or they perhaps would not share our
human
um reluctance to hurt other people
exactly imagine
just hypothetically
we have a system an AI system now it's
not it's not really smart than the human
stuff no super intelligence doesn't even
have to human level intelligence not
even human level you know it's not that
smart but it's like pretty smart you
know it can like you know it's like you
know 90 IQ 100 IQ do some thinking you
can do some planning but also it's read
every book ever written it has Perfect
Memory it can be runs you know at you
know superhuman speeds and mini copies
in parallel and you give this into the
hands you know maybe this thing can't do
planning very well yet or it has like
some
problems or whatever right but then you
just give it to a human or a group of
humans
and now suddenly imagine you had access
to a group of perfectly loyal you know
they never snitch they never get tired
they never break they never turn you
know sociopaths the the complete
sociopath they'll do anything you want
they're not evil per se AIS wouldn't be
evil per se they wouldn't be like you
know statistic but they will be so
sociopathic they would have no qualms if
you said hey maximize my chance of
becoming president and they calculate oh
assassinated Camp is a good idea well
they would why would the AI hesitate
it's just optimizing a goal function so
when humans think about
optimizing for goals it's extremely
implicit that we have these constraints
that we don't you there's like taboo
areas like if you want to become
president you won't even think of
killing the president because you'd be
like no I'd never do that you could also
argue on consequentialist grounds that
like oh it wouldn't work or you'd get in
trouble blah blah blah but to assert to
a large curiosity you just wouldn't do
that like I would just not do that I
like like purely like deontologically I
would just not to do that but
if you have a system that's only
optimizing
well so the danger
I see from AI in the short term is not
you know super intelligence or like you
know emerging things those might also
happen like this is those are strictly
worse scenarios in the scenario I'm
describing the scenario I'm describing
is the least worst scenario that still
ruins everything what I'm thinking about
is systems that are perfect sociopaths
that are just optimizing there's a great
post unless you're on called optimality
is the tiger an agents are its teeth
which is related to this as well where
you these can be systems are not agents
it's not necessarily the systems or
agents it's not necessarily that they're
you know interacting with the world or
whatever these can just be like
very simple AI systems they're just very
intelligent right and they're just
optimizing for something and to optimize
for something they might just
cold-heartedly conclude oh well I've
simulated
how to you know kill the president first
run this piece of code and uh with an
Internet connected device or you know
and then that spawns some kind of agent
that you know or or you know some kind
of agent process that you know do does
some kind of actions in the environment
they're like necessary to assassinate
the president or whatever so in the
short term you're mostly worried about
these tool AI systems such as for
example uh gpt3 would be an example of
this used by humans with uh with goals
that that conflict with those of broader
societies so say for example we want to
no it's worse than that okay that's
that's that's still one of the positive
scenarios
there are even worse scenarios than that
it's even worse so if that is Acer it's
a minimum vile thing like this is the
one most people agree with I'm like hey
imagine you have like you know some
intelligence service or whatever from a
hostile nation and they have access to a
group of never you know never sleeping
sociopaths they'll be like oh so
this is the existence proof that the
world is unstable like every single
person I've talked to from intelligence
services or like security if I told them
hey imagine your adversary had 100
perfectly loyal sociopaths that will do
everything and are also as smart as Von
Newman
how would you defend against that they
would be like we're like like
that like there is no defense against
that that is like insane so this is the
existence proof that the world is
unstable
now things get even worse so I don't
even think you need a human like I my
default outcome scenario doesn't even
involve a human doing this this is like
if we get to this scenario we're already
one of the better timelines
my Mainline prediction is is that we
should die before we get to the scenario
what's going to happen is instead as we
build
systems that you know continue to
increase intelligence and generality we
have them you know training themselves
or in the environment or whatever
Gathering new data from the internet
playing in video games simulation
whatever right you know deepmind just
released that paper of like an age in
the teacher self how to like you know
collect diamonds in Minecraft and
whatnot you know that kind of stuff and
we just you know just scale that up
scale it up oh suddenly it has art and
language and no doesn't use hand access
anymore and suddenly
I know something weird happens so my
prediction is so my true prediction
which is more higher shock level which
is like you know might make sense to you
or the audience but you know it doesn't
work as well on like you know government
officials is then like and then
something weird happens
we have these systems that no one
intended them to do anything you know
intelligence didn't intend for humans to
develop culture or to didn't intend for
people to develop any certain ideology
or preferences or opinions or whatever
but
as you become more powerful they're
interacting with their environment their
you know have these like discontinuous
capability gains and like you know like
those you know sums of s-curs whatever
so like to be clear I think all of this
will look completely smooth from the
perspective of loss so if you look at
like the Lost graphs of these things I
think there will be no anomalies I do
not predict any anomalies I think things
will go totally smoothly as predicted
you know and then at some point you know
you know the difference between like you
know GPT 4 and gp3 on loss is like not
that massive you know but it could do a
bunch of crazy new things that like gpd3
can't do I think that's just going to
keep happening and then people are going
to start using them for benign tasks you
know people are going to start
automating you know writing a system
you know it's like your clerical work
and you know stuff for coding you know
stuff like that like all this benign
stuff and I think this is all going to
be completely benign until it very
suddenly is
and then very suddenly we have these
systems that
start taking actions and we don't really
know why or what they're doing but it's
like we're like ah it's fine you know
some rohf you know just kind of like you
know
it's fine and what the term you just
used what does that mean oh sorry uh
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback this is a commonly used
technique at the moment which I have
strong technical disagreements with
um basically the idea is you take like
language models or systems like this and
you train them to optimize a model of
what humans would like so yeah like
humans look at various outputs of the
model and rate them you know thumbs up
thumbs down you make the model like
output the thumbs up ones more and the
thumbs down ones ones less sort of and
this is sometimes touted as alignment
technique I do not think that is a very
fair description of what the technique
actually does because the the problem
here is that you you don't really know
which goals you're encoding in the agent
you don't know how the agent this or how
the AI model is understanding your
thumbs down or thumbs up exactly it's
like this is encoding human preferences
in the ontology of weight stiffs which
is just such an alien way like okay I
show you a 175 billion you know list of
numbers of like slightly changing
floating Point numbers I'm saying like
Okay cool this is your preferences here
encoded super legible
well no like of course not like what
what the hell am I supposed to do with
this this is an ontology I understand
why would you expect your ontology to
fit into this like there's like some
alien comes down from Earth and it comes
out from the space and he's like ah I've
been looking at you yet you guys really
like for larval don't you hey like what
the is for Laura we're like yeah I
got you guys and then he goes off to do
whatever that is that's kind of like how
rohf is it's like so you you can't
understand what you've encoded by
looking at the weights of of the network
and that's no that's that's a research
Paradigm trying to to interpret uh these
weights and and trying to extract what
information is encoded but that's uh
it's uh it's definitely lagging behind
progress in the models themselves
exactly exactly so we there's a there's
a fun little experiment we did a
conjecture where we looked at two
different models that were trained
slightly differently but this is not
actually rhf we thought it was our rhf
turns out it wasn't at least assuming
openness telling the truth which you
know you know
um basically we saw two models two GPT
models
and one of the models is you asked it
for a random number
and you looked at the you know output
probability over like digits it was like
pretty random actually
not perfect like 42 was like slightly
more likely than others but um
overall it's like pretty smooth uh
distribution but then if you look at
this other model this instruct model and
you asked it for a random number it
would put like almost all its
probability Mass onto like two numbers
it was like I had like two favorite
numbers
so this is really interesting so what I
interpret kind of is going on here I
don't think openai like
tried to tell the model to like these
numbers no I I don't think that's what
happened at all what I expect what
happened is it's just that you know
we're training on just like you know you
know being useful to humans just showing
a bunch of examples whatever and for
some reason something about you know the
thumbs up things had some weird
correlations or some weird connections
somewhere something that for some reason
you know just made it really like these
numbers just like really upvote these
numbers
this is not intentional so the
interesting thing here is that oh it has
bigger numbers that's like you know kind
of funny you know it's kind of harmless
and like this has been solve the newer
models like they have much more data now
and like they don't have
it or so
you know it's more of an interesting
idea the interesting thing here is not
the exact example is that like what else
are they encoding
you know what else are in those weight
updates who knows we don't know it's an
example of how seemingly random goals
could arise in an AI model and suddenly
exactly suddenly the the model starts
acting uh in in a way that to us look it
looks weird but it's because we've
encoded some goals that we don't
understand and and then the the AI
safety problem the alignment problem the
control problem is then when these goals
begin diverging from the goals of
humanity or from the goals of the lab or
company developing the AI that is where
things go off the rails
um the way we've been talking about it
here
and the the framing of the fragile world
I think
I think it's it's a great way to frame
it because it underlines how how serious
this problem is and perhaps how
intractable it is do you do you think AI
safety can be can be solved by by
Humanity uh given the fact that we have
we have a mixed record of containing
dangerous Technologies we've we have
extremely strict standards for nuclear
energy production and for biological
Laboratories and still there are
accidents there are uh these these have
happened so if if the failure rate uh or
if the security has extremely high and
and the failure rate extremely low for
this to succeed can we succeed can of
course there's no law of physics that
forbids us from solving the problem
building a super and aligned super
intelligence
and having a wonderful future there was
nothing whatsoever that forbids this
from happening
it's completely allowed to happen by
physics this is a path that is open to
us this is it we have to be clear about
this this is a path that is open we have
not it's quite interesting we live in a
timeline where we have not yet obviously
lost
we're not in a timeline where like
everything's out of control you know AIS
are already spinning up and like taking
you over governments like you know or
like you know you know weird sociopaths
are in power or whatever that's not the
case
the paths are clearly still open we can
still win
but
we have to be realistic here
the truth of the matter is I don't
expect us to solve it no I don't expect
us to race rise to the challenge in most
timelines I expect us to fail
this is a type of problem
that humanity is especially bad itself
this is a like it's like I started call
it like level two epistemology problem
this is a problem that is not like a
normal scientific problem where we're
like an iterate over and over and like
failure isn't catastrophic and you know
it's not a problem if we can like you
know if we don't have you know we don't
get everything right in the first try
people are like mostly aligned on the
same on the same page and whatever
that's not where we're at it's not where
we're at at all this is a much much much
harder problem this is a problem where
if we if we get it wrong on the critical
first try
that's it no iteration
we might be able to iterate on like
Proto versions of it right but like
we're this is less like the nuclear bomb
and more like the nuclear bomb position
if it would ignite the atmosphere
and
you know there was the thing in in Los
Alamos where they weren't sure if it was
going to ignite the atmosphere there's
like a possibility that it could ignite
the whole atmosphere and it did like
some crazy like mathematics like three
days before the test and it still gave
them like a 30 chance it might and
ignite the the atmosphere and they still
did it like imagine imagine being in
that room and being like well all right
it's only 30 that we will kill everyone
forever
but I mean the general sure is shouting
so let's do it anyways like this is the
state of mankind like like imagine
imagine being at the stake where you can
both believe
that that is 30 chance of the world you
know ending but the scary Alpha ape is
yelling at me so I should do it like
that's that's the state of mankind or
perhaps you're uh too curious not to do
it that that will be even more even more
Sinister in in some sense it is I think
for a lot of scientists that was the
case the case I think for a lot of them
so there's this
truly Darkly funny quote I don't
remember exactly but it's from Von
Neumann where he's like oh you know the
goal of science you know for scientists
is to do science no matter the
consequences it doesn't matter if it
causes harm it must be done because you
know you must do it and I'm like
what like like so
in my personal life
one of the mantras I live my life by one
of the things I like to repeat to myself
to like Orient myself through life is
the same is the the saying don't be
stupid
now this is a very different saying from
be smart because be smart is hard I
can't guarantee I'm smart so dear
listener I cannot guarantee to you that
any of the things I'm saying is smart I
can't guarantee you that I can't
guarantee you that I won't I'll be smart
in all scenarios
but like I'm pretty
pretty that I still I'm still stupid
sometimes but like
especially Orient yourself around
recognizing when you're being stupid and
just not doing that you can already
outperform like Everyone by like a crazy
Martin because most people do stupid
things all the time it's crazy how much
times people spend just like loading
their guns and shooting themselves into
the foot over and over again like and
the same goes for Humanity on a
civilizational level you think yep
absolutely if you man you would
literally just shooting stop stop
yourself on the foot I'm
saying you know you know in you know
become enlightened and Ascend into the
you know a truly you know beautiful
society which by the way is also
possible everyone's just being stupid
but even if we would just not to be
stupid and not shoot ourselves in the
foot over and over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again if you could just do that man man
would I feel better about a future but
like prediction markets are still
illegal in the US like we are shooting
ourselves in the foot so hard every
single day all the time it's in it's
just truly patterning like if alien came
down for space to be like oh
what the did you guys do what would
it mean for Humanity to not be stupid in
terms of AI safety what should we do
what is what is the scenario what is a
how do we survive this if if we were to
not be stupid uh so that's a great
question so I'm gonna I I'm going to
give an answer for what will we do if we
were not stupid and what will we do if
we were smart that's what I want to hear
yeah so first answer what we do for not
stupid
everyone will just kind of look at each
other and like huh the CGI thing you
know seems like the actress for how guys
yep we should probably not do it right
yep and so they didn't
that would be the non-stupid version
like you know back to Alan Turing people
have predicted this like this is not
like some crazy new thing or whatever
it's like it's obviously predictable
Alan Turing already predicted all of
this basically and like you know I like
you know actually good and stuff like
this so let's let's sorry but let's
pause here for a second actually do you
think it's possible to slow down uh
progress in AI capabilities research so
yeah you think it's likely that we will
coordinate do you think it's it's uh
won't we just hand off the the torch to
less scrupulous companies or Labs uh if
if say say open mind uh sorry uh a deep
mind and open AI began collaborating on
slowing down uh progress in their
research yeah wouldn't it just be then
the next uh most uh
you know Advanced company taking the
lead so the original question you asked
me is what will we do if Humanity would
stop being stupid
so you're now asking okay what happens
if you continue to be stupid because
obviously if you were not stupid the
other labs would just also not do it so
those are two different questions just
want to make that clear
um so you're asking okay what do we do
if we continue to be stupid
um I can answer that question and they
have many models here
um I expect us to be continue to be
stupid to be clear and so so soon we
continue to be stupid
um then like
so there's just two there's two parts of
this I guess two main parts I'll put
into this first part is Will others
catch up how much will they catch up et
cetera et cetera
second does this question even make
sense
first answer
I actually genuinely think that no one
other than like the like top labs are
relevant I don't think China's relevant
at all like I know I I think it's a
terrible meme they're not going to catch
up they're so far behind who cares like
I think this is actually genuinely a
terrible meme this is like a real like
like Insidious insidiously bad meme is
that so it's relevant for longer
timelines if we're dealing with longer
timelines I mean
I recommend everyone just you know start
solving politics because oh no
um
if we're in short timelines doesn't
matter like like well politics matters
because like China Russia whatever like
Russia obviously doesn't matter they
obviously don't have the capabilities
and like people have these like really
weird like orientalist like mindset
around China like this like Boogeyman
that has like all this capabilities but
like if you actually look at China like
actually like
really look at it and like how science
is done there and like the bureaucracy
and like whatever
China's one of the worst places in the
world to do science like they are like
doing science China is a nightmare it's
so bureaucratic it's so slow it's so you
know ideology you know suffuses every
part of it
they are like so much of it is marketing
like just like the Chinese government
markets itself as good as science super
super hard and they have a large
population which includes lots of
brilliant people who are succeeding
despite the Chinese government
like to be clear a lot of the smartest
people in the world are Chinese like
there's a lot of truly brilliant Chinese
people and you know they succeed despite
the Chinese government not thanks to it
you know it's just because of their you
know the perseverance of the human soul
and mind these people can do great work
and I would never and most of those go
to the US do their good work because you
know if you're a smart brilliant Chinese
person you know student or whatever why
would you want to stay there with all
this bureaucracy and politics and all
this you know if you go to the
US you make tons of money and you can do
your research much better so so if we
can if we can rule China out as as
taking the lead if the if the U.S were
to begin not advancing AI capabilities
what about just the uh say the the
second tier of of American AI companies
say perhaps a Facebook or a Google brain
or something like this yep so there's
several factors that go into that uh one
is is that
they don't actually want to kill
everybody like like and they are
mostly you know like not insane
like they might be like not super
convinced and they might be like normal
amounts of irrational but they're not
like politics amount of irrational so
like
you can talk to them like you can just
talk to Mark Zuckerberg like he is weird
and whatever but like he is a person you
can talk to and also these are all
people who do listen to the US
government
you know if the U.S government said no
more
AGI there would be none
of course that's not what would actually
happen my actual models are more that
government takes over and starts ruining
everything because governments aren't
capable enough to do this like actual
non-street things so this brings us back
to not being stupid so in the real world
this is not impossible governments have
levers to do this it is a thing that is
like within their like jurisdiction and
like
power but it is not within their
executive ability I think to at least
not on short timelines or at least not
effectively I
hope I'm wrong about this and this is
something we can like figure out so
actually it's worse than that
I'm actually very skeptical about
governments designed to slow down AGI
uh I think this is not a good idea
and or well It's Tricky and but the
reason I think this is because of my
model of governments and how incompetent
and like contradict and like you know
internally inconsistent they are
in a sense having
labs in control is not ideal but it is
there are more concentrated points of
coordination it's easy to coordinate
with deepmind than it is with the US
government
and
whether if we have longer timelines in
five years even maybe on the five year
timeline it's not going to matter
because governments are going to get
involved obviously like obviously so
there's no way you know like intelligent
services are just going to let the
go on if like if we have like you know
10-year timelines or 20-year timelines
no way intelligence services or I mean
I'm pretty sure all these organizations
are already infiltrated by intelligence
agencies I would be surprised if
intelligence agencies were listening to
us right now I have been cited in the
CIA paper did you know that
I didn't know that I have
um
that's probably fine right
but yeah
so
one thing that government especially U.S
government is very good at is reacting
to National threats that is like the
only thing that makes the U.S government
get its together is when the
Pentagon says this needs to get done
then the US government can actually do
things so
if this continues to you know Babble
along as these little like future is
thin or kind of maybe economics thing
then I don't expect governments to do
much if this becomes like a national
threat type scenario then I expect the
Behemoth to Lumber into action and I
expect it to break everything by default
unless we you know somehow
direct to this and like you know help
the Behemoth make a non-stupid choice I
don't think you can make a smart choice
I think it's like genuinely possible for
like governments to be smart I think
this is like too complicated but I think
it's possible to make governments be not
stupid
and would that be by a piece of
legislation governing how uh how the how
the governments would govern AI or what
are you thinking in terms of helping
governments not be stupid
the truth is the government is composed
of people
it's composed of you know lots of civil
servants and politicians and bureaucrats
and
uh generals and you know intelligence
Service agents so on these are all
people
and these are all people you can talk to
these are all I've been surprised by how
much I have like you know just like
contacted some like government officials
and they were quite happy to talk to me
and I could just answer the questions
and that was quite nice and I'd like to
do more of this I have this is a thing
I've updated very heavily on over the
last year is how much
again trying to make these people act
smartly in the scenario at scale maybe
individuals like I've met some pretty
smart people in government actually
um some not
I met some pretty pretty smart people
you can't do that scale but you can help
people be not stupid because it's also
in their interest not these students
so
I think the things for example that I am
doing and I'll be very interested if any
of your readers out the listeners out
there are you know working government
intelligence Services whatever and
you're trying to understand these
problems better and how to do this my
email is open please let me know I would
be happy to help I think this is
important to like inform people like you
know have give people better bottles of
these kinds of things how we can reason
about kind of things I don't think
there'll be like one piece of
legislation that fixes all of this or
whatever I think the way government
really works is like not like that like
it's a lot more backroom deals dinners
you know who knows who who owes who a
favor you know what are the lines of you
know various parties and whatever and I
think the ideal thing I would want is
that just to have
everyone kind of be on the on the not
stupid side just be like yeah let's
let's like not be stupid about this
let's like I'll take this seriously
let's like fund alignment research like
Jesus Christ please like let's just like
have DARPA pull you know push 10 billion
dollars into a lot into alignment
research why not like this is like for a
government this is like yeah they can
they can make this happen like the
number of people that need to sign off
to get like a hundred million dollars
until like until like a project is like
shockingly low it's like it's like
depending on the government it could be
like two people
so
let's just do that like there's like 200
people maybe in the whole world working
full-time on alignment if governments
just like said even just said this is a
national priority even if they don't
like put funds into anything basically
all like massive amounts of Academia
will just like Lumber into motion and
because it becomes High status now it
becomes the thing to be working on it
becomes a legitimate real scientific
problem you know like you know rubber
stamped you know this is a you know you
are a high status person for working on
this
cool and just that would cause I think a
massive shift in like how many people
take this problem seriously and like how
academics are taking problems seriously
there is a massive risk in doing all
these things because whenever you get
lots of people involved you know
politics gets important
so
Ideal World would be of course you know
oh turns out alignment is super easy and
we just solved in our basements and here
it is and everyone's happy
I don't expect that's how things are
going to go so if we're realistic you do
some real real politic here then what we
need to do is to be realistic that
people will get interested this is of
interest to everyone this is of interest
to governments intelligence agencies
academics everyone
Let's help people not be stupid let's
talk to them let's be friendly you know
let's say that DARPA began funding
alignment research to the tune of of a
hundred million dollars or whatever you
would pick a number
um and
you know could this be counterproductive
because the money would be used to
increase capabilities isn't that isn't
that a a pretty uh live danger
um if we look at for example the critics
of open AI we'll tell a story in which
openai was founded with safety in mind
but then increased capabilities uh of of
AI and thereby increased AI risk and
perhaps the same thing could happen with
a government grant into alignment
research of course this is the default
thing that happens everyone's stupid
remember like being smart would be just
the government nationalizes everything
creates the alignment Manhattan Project
solves the problem we're done that's the
smart solution we're never going to get
that that is like don't even think about
that it's not possible yeah so it's not
it's not it's not that interesting
interesting to discuss what we were
doing in a very smart world so what
we're trying to avoid being stupid
instead yes we're trying to okay so like
so I'm thinking about like Pareto
improvements here I think I'm not stupid
we are currently in a world where there
is no government funding for alignment
this is stupid like it's not just like
not smart it's also stupid if we had
like okay 10 billion dollar alignment
research and it all goes to you know
something irrelevant or something
dangerous I'm like okay that's not good
but this is a less stupid world and I
expect a world that is already at this
point will be more amenable to
interventions that help of safety and
Alignment than the ones we're currently
in of course because it's backfire yes
obviously like anything involving you
know lumbering behemoths you know tends
to involve you know
um low back risk you know when you when
a giant monsters attacking Tokyo and you
summon Godzilla like you know Godzilla
could probably beat the monster but
there's gonna be a lot of reconstruction
costs you know by default even if
Godzilla is the good guy
so how could government go intervention
go wrong here what what are ways in
which the US government could break
things no I mean oh God do I even want
to give them ideas and that I need
plenty of things I mean obviously as you
just said the obvious one is just you
know funding capabilities work obviously
um the second one which I think is just
extremely likely to happen is just they
only fund military applications if they
don't actually fund safety they just
fund like okay how do we maximize you
know military applications and whatever
and that obviously kills you
um
another one like I actually talked to
someone about this a while back he said
something very interesting so
um I was talking about interpretability
research with them which is you know a
very common Topic in AI alignment
research and
she basically said um
that so he worked for the uh in military
industrial complex and he said that the
number one thing
currently holding military back from
deploying AIS at White scale is lack of
interpretability and accountability so
every increase in interpretability
increases the military adoption of AI
this is I think something that a lot of
people in like the yeah safety world do
not consider when they consider the cost
benefit analysis of interpretability
research I do I still think it's worth
it but it is something that you should
have in your Calculus
so these are like some obvious ways that
the government can mess up another
obvious way they can mess it up is to
politicize it it becomes a left-wing
ripening you know red blue team issue
that seems
that's another way things could be
stupid like the non-stupid thing is well
obviously this is not red or blue this
is like you know we're all it's all in
all of our interest to you know be able
to control our technology like no one
benefits from this not be case so you
know let's just not be stupid about that
unfortunately this is the kind of thing
humans tend to be really stupid about
you know like you know climate change or
whatever yeah let's let's go back to the
question of government grants for AI
alignment research uh another thing that
could go wrong here is that AI alignment
research becomes a buzzword uh and it
becomes it comes to mean uh something
else that than what it originally meant
and it becomes a way to attract funding
to your to your existing Pro projects
and so on is there a way to to avoid
this is there a way to be strict about
what you're it's what you're trying to
fund
um without it drifting into becoming too
broad and coming to mean something else
no that would involve being smart
is there any hope here for for what
could we do to to constrain what we're
trying to fund oh there's I mean there's
lots of marginal things you can do here
but actually I think this is a massive
mistake that a lot of funders have been
making here is that
um so this is a actually a genuine
critique I have of like EA and like you
know AI safety funding is there
extremely risk-averse like they build
themselves as like oh you know we're
funding the crazy stuff no one else is
funding or like you know we're willing
to do things whatever
but they're not actually like DARPA is
way less risk-averse than like you know
open fill or or whatever right
understandable it's because DARPA has
way more money so like you know this is
not this is like an understandable thing
that you know maybe open field would be
more conservative because they have much
less resources and you know
you know dartbook you know could do all
kinds of crazy things but like I would
expect that
so like when DARPA funds things like
they fund a lot of crazy stupid
and like they
and a little bit like open field funds
like you know one person that turns out
to be controversial or like does
something stupid or whatever and then
people are like hmm using my donated
money to fund this guy like that seems
like an inappropriate use about like
like no good deed goes unpunished like
if DARPA funds some guy making an
invisibility cloak or whatever right you
know it's DARPA we know whatever they do
weird mil Tech stuff that doesn't work
but if a philanthropic organization you
know Bill Melinda Gates Foundation funds
like one company that turns out to be
Shady or whatever everyone's of course
immediately on their case no good deed
goes unpunged it's really funny how
if you were a rich billionaire and
you're just selfish you don't really get
criticized for that very much it's kind
of like you're like yeah obviously but
it's like the it's called The Copenhagen
interpretation of Ethics if you're a
billionaire and you try to solve a
problem then everyone and you fail to
solve the problem you get way more
than all the billionaires that did
nothing
this is a this is again Humanity
shooting themselves in the foot so
abysmally hard but you should get credit
for trying to solve a problem even if
you fail but the exact opposite happens
there's a large reason of why people are
so low authentic is because trying and
failing is gives you more social
negative than not even trying
so this is a massive problem and
so when I think about government grants
yeah I expect most of it to go to
and I expect most of it not
going to work but you know and to be
clear if I wanted government grants the
way I would want it to go is DARPA type
DARPA is very different from like how
like other Grant making works if we do
the other Grant making also fine
but I also think there's ways that would
help but ideal case would be like DARPA
like high risk like weirdness because we
don't know know how to solve alignment
alignment is not like a low risk like
man we just need this amount of money to
build the alignment machine and then
we're fine no no this is Blue Sky
research like there's like you know we
if you look at like you know current
alignment approaches you know some were
like pretty simple and reasonable others
involve like you know retro causal you
know a causal decision theoretic
multiversal you know decision Theory
simulations or whatever right and you're
like
is either like
is either of these gonna work I I don't
know probably not but sure as hell
someone should fund them like someone
should try is there a way to earn money
by solving alignment
I mean
uh depending on what you mean by that
obviously yes I mean in a sense that if
you solve alignment you make infinite
money obviously like you solved
everything like the the thing holding
back Humanity's progress I think the
limiting factor the bottleneck and human
economic progress wasn't the only the
biggest bottleneck intelligence is that
if everyone was twice as smart oh man
could you imagine could you imagine
you're just like the median human had
like 200 IQ could you imagine what
society would be like oh the policies
the efficiency all the science the you
know the you know the social like
systems we could build the coordination
technology we could Implement like oh
could you imagine and this is just like
a modest increase of intelligence you
know this is like if every you know you
know if everyone was like this is still
a human range like like 200 IQ is like
still within human range like there are
people that are that smart you know
so like that's still like not as as good
like anywhere near as good as things
could be if we have like you know AI or
like do super intelligence that is like
you know running things and developing
technology and coordinating and you know
doing economic activity and whatnot we
could have you know everything like you
know if you have an AGI and it does what
you want it to do I mean price to tell
that you're cancer tell it to you know
trade infinite money in the stock market
tell it to just no more Wars please just
like go negotiate with everybody and
solve all politics yeah I was simply
interested in what the best funding
model for solving this problem is
whether it's it's non-profit or
government grants or whether it could be
a for-profit company or some new uh
legal construction uh like a limited
profit uh open AI style great question
uh this is the thing I I've often
obviously thought about a lot and so I
mean if we were a smart Society we would
have you know like you know impact
grants what is an impact Grant so
um
I don't even know exactly all the exact
details that you'll do this whatever
this is a new funding instrument where
basically you can like you sell impact
certificates I think that's what it's
called actually maybe I'm thinking of
impact Mark is not grants
one or the other and like basically
you're creating a new charity it will
work the following way it involves the
following people and now you sell shares
in the impact you say like you know I'm
sure spelling uh saying 100 shares or a
million shares they're like the
philanthropic benefit of this existing
so then people who think this is good
this should exist and buy the shares to
fund your operation so like this would
be an example of like something that a
smart society would have it would have
like this would be like super common and
then the the price of these certificates
rise when there's more impact from the
from the company uh who shares we're
talking about yeah that's yeah and then
you can also do more like like this this
is just an example of like a simple
system that like again showing just like
how
humans are you know
so far away from like smarter societies
who have even better systems like even
better like a common funding you know
credit funding and like you know Common
you know Goods funding kind of research
and
let's just take one objection to impact
grants uh which is just a question
whether we can measure uh impact uh
appropriately for for these grants to
work and and objectively in a sense so
we can so this is information that's
that's out there objectively that that
we can trade on uh do you think that's
possible or do you think that's likely
to happen in a in a smart Society of
course that's possible but we're not in
a smart Society so like this is an
example of a technology that only works
in a smart Society it doesn't work in
arts like I don't think impact markets
work in our society they just don't
um it's not that they fundamentally
can't work they just don't work for
practical contingent reasons that could
be overcome in the future but in the way
things currently are no no they just
don't work so would you actually want to
be pragmatic
about funds and this is like you know so
for listeners don't know I run an AI
alignment research company conjecture
and we are a for-profit company and
that's not a coincidence the reasoning
for that is quite simply that that is
the best form I think currently to be
able to raise large amounts of money and
to be able to have an ongoing supply of
money to fund research and do these kind
of stuff if you don't have like some
kind of crazy billionaire backing or
something
um even there there's problems like you
know diversification and stuff the truth
is that if you look at how our society
allocates resources money power Etc the
currently again this is a contingent
truth this is not a ideological
statement this is just a contingent
truth about how reality currently is set
up but this could like change in five
years
is that currently the vehicle through
which it is most likely to go from zero
dollars to a billion dollars in a short
period of time as a startup
this is a contingent truth about how our
markets are currently set up you know 50
years ago that was not true you know and
maybe five years from now that won't be
true but currently
VC markets however startups that are
build you know software-based products
that you know are useful you know scale
very very quickly to very very many
users are the most effective way to gain
very very large amounts of resources
very quickly is you know unless you
happen to have some kind of weird other
scenario but like those aren't scalable
for the most part because also our
markets are way more robust and way more
Diversified sources of funding and so on
then for example having one billionaire
the Europe Patron that might you know
might be great and you know there's some
billionaire wants to come by and you
know hand us a billion dollars happy to
talk but
um
practically you know as we saw for
example with the FTX scenario
um there are blow up risks let's say
yeah and so perhaps the main objection
to the for-profit model is that the
incentives won't be properly aligned to
to do the the actually
um societally societally a beneficial
thing uh you will be pushed into uh
doing the profitable thing as opposed to
the the to the good thing yeah but
that's not a property of for profits
that's a property of how we as Society
has sent credit if we had impact markets
if we had you know benevolent you know
billionaire patrons or whatever then we
would be assigning credit differently to
study money is fundamentally a credit
assignment mechanism it is a
reinforcement mechanism there's a
mechanism that gives subparts of a
computational graph ability to do more
computation to do more actions we reward
people ideally by you know credit sign
is a fundamentally hard problem like
credit assignment is extremely extremely
hard and it's you know it's massive
Rabbit Hole there and the fundamental
like
the fundamental like you know
um Insight from like mercantilism first
and later capitalism is how we do this
credit assignment there is other
economic systems that do credit
assignment differently and the the
fundamental progress of capitalism is
the idea of how we assign credit to like
you know people capital or you know
labor or whatever in certain ways you
can agree or disagree with this is the
right way to do this but it has been
very efficient it's very it's the way
our things currently work it's the
efficient most efficient system you
currently have now capitalism is in many
ways natural like you know you give
people money for things you want trade
is a very natural fundamental thing to
build a system or credit assignment on
top of not perfect for example
capitalism has large problems pricing
externalities and like Commons this is a
failure mode of capitalism so I would
expect a very Advanced alien society
would not be capitalist they would
definitely not be socialist but they
would be like some third thing you know
they would have some kind of you know
prediction Market you know Commons
trading you know based systems you know
some like Robin Hansen designed economy
or whatever you know
um
and
so the fact that there are these
incentives are contingent a saint a not
stupid society would have different
mechanisms
they would have different incentives
but
there's a great there's a great essays
like um I forgot who wrote it wrote it
and it was like incentives aren't the
problem you are
it's like if you have bad incentives and
you act on them well you're bad like you
know you did the bad thing like sure
there's like some amount of exculpation
here in the sense that like you know you
can say like well you know I didn't have
full Freedom here there was incentives
blah blah but ultimately you took the
action dude like you know it's true that
there are systems that are so corrupt or
so you know 1984 oppressive or whatever
you're just in that case yeah
you're obviously like you know
like what do you want me to say like
yeah if you're if you're controlled by
some like crushing Market Force or
authoritarian regime or something and
every time you try to resist you get
shot or you you you starve then yeah you
just die you just fail like yeah
obviously
it's
surprising
that
um we have as much Freedom as we do like
people are allowed to spend their
resources in weird ways uh you know
people are allowed to be eccentric to a
large degree not infinitely and very
differently depending on people and the
fact Elon Musk is allowed to exist is
like I mean just look at the guy like
like you must be a pretty you know high
IQ Society to allow something like this
to go on like I mean it's genuinely I
mean I'm being a bit snarky but like
he's so weird you're so erratic and he
like does so many like crazy things like
potentially dangerous things that like
and somebody and he has so much power
and he's still allowed to have this
power it's like you know in like an
authoritarian regime this wouldn't
fly you know if he was Chinese that
ain't gonna fly you know they're not
gonna allow something like this this
and so
in a sense
I'm saying that this is the best we have
in a stupid Society is this like
capitalist Freedom it's not perfect it's
very bad actually it's quite stupid
um but it is the
you know what's the alternative right
like you know the alternative is okay
you do a non-profit you have no money
you die cool you start game over
alternative is you have a patron okay so
first of all assume you have a patron
second well the patron probably got his
money through capitalism so he's using
his weirdness capitalism points on You
by proxy and now you're also tied to him
so now you have the blow up risk of your
billionaire buddy being you know now he
has a sentence but the incentives of the
billionaires you know expresses on you
are
also extremely powerful and like you
know
maybe you know Dustin Moskowitz or
whatever is a great guy but like you
know there's a lot of them who are not
what do you think of companies tying
themselves to the Mast by having
windfall classes where for example if
they successfully develop AGI they then
have some Clause stating that they will
distribute the profits from this Venture
in a
say a more fair way after they have
returned money to investors
definitely cute marketing stunt
but not substantially important look let
me put it very simply right like you
know so I run a company random CEO you
know and whatever right and sure there's
like
there are things you could do you can
have like a board and you can have like
shareholder meetings you do all these
kind of things but look if me and my
co-founders were like Hey we're gonna
up this company
because nothing can stop you like it's
like
if someone finds the Philosopher's Stone
and he has a handgun you're like what
are you gonna do you can like you can
complain about oh no wait you have a
contract that you said you would give me
the Philosopher's Stone and like okay
she too like like if if
a person with a philosopher's stone and
a handgun is sufficiently on the line
you're just screwed so like sure you can
sign these contracts and maybe that
makes people feel better but it's very
funny because like if you if you ask
this question to someone from like the
Middle Ages or something they would
laugh in your face they would be like
what the king signed the contract with
you like so what like who's gonna stop
the king like and so I think it's just
this thing about power is that it
depends on how the situation goes of
course so like there are so
to turn down the cynical dial just a
little bit from here
I do think people doing this for being
for a large degree actually quite
genuine not all of them some people this
is really just safety washing some of
them are being quite genuine they're
really trying to make things work and I
respect them for that I think it's
really nice so I think the biggest value
of these things is more in just like
signaling that they tried and like
they're trying but of course any genuine
signal of Honesty will quickly be
co-opted by anyone who's not honest
but it's it might be an interesting
first start it might be a a milestone or
a symbol uh where we
we say that this is not some this is
what we intend to do and perhaps then
the the actually trying to do that thing
comes later on after you've you've uh
you've stickmulled that that this is
what you want to do I mean sure these
are all coordination mechanisms of
signaling yeah yeah I'm seeing from
those perspective yeah it's of course
it's valuable like you know I like I'm
I'm being very cynical right now you
know because also you know podcast mode
right
um but
um
signals matter
you know uh signals matter reputations
matter honor matters like these things
do matter but like we should not not
delude ourselves here right that like
people lie you know I I'm sorry if this
is shocking to any listeners but uh
people lie like a lot all the time and
but they change their minds you know a
lot of people promise very big things
when Good Times comes but once you know
War comes suddenly you know you see how
people really are
so I'm interested in these mechanisms
from the perspective of what they say
about the people like I know some of
these organizations and I know like some
of the soft process that went into these
things and like wow you really tried
like that's that's like really
heartwarming like I actually feel better
about you as a person I trust you more
now there's other people where I'm like
oh yeah this is a marketing Center I do
not trust you more
um
so the interesting thing for me is what
it says about the people or like or what
it signals about the people and also
what it doesn't signal about people I'm
not optimistic about the legal
mechanisms like I I just like I would
love if they would work like it the
problem is legal mechanisms like these
involve having enforcement power
and like if you have AGI uh yeah who's
gonna force that exactly
all right perfect let's let's end it
here and then perhaps move into the to
the semi or pseudo lightning round as I
call it